[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كيف هو الوضع هنا على هذا الموقع
ما مدى جدية مدى صعوبة
كن تحت النار
نحو 100
المصنع و
ثم سأرى الملاح
كما تعلم ، هناك بيانات سواء بقيت أم لا
سو بالتحديد الجيش الأوكراني
كانت هذه مجرد رحلة
كل الرجال
كل شيء على ما يرام إلى ما سبق
[موسيقى]
كان ناقصًا على الأرجح أو عبدًا نعم
أ
هذا مفهوم ، لكن ليس لديك خسائر
بشكل عام يتكون بشكل عام من نقطة الصفر
جمهورية الشيشان كما هو الحال دائما
يظهر مولعا جدا من متى
سوف تأخذ آزوفستال
إذا كان بعض التناوب الوطني
آزوف ما قد تريدهم
العتاد نعم بالطبع نحن لهذا الغرض
قالوا هذا ما يأتي
من الواضح أننا جميعاً سنكون قوقازيين وملتحين
هذا الصديق من صب الشراب نحن الآن
وصلنا ، لا نرى أحدا سوى الناس
لقد تصرفوا مثل الفئران تشاك 2g لنا شخصيا
مع تعريف معهم لم يكن ممكنا
يجتمع